les recherches ont été longues et
difficiles et se sont étendus sur un
vaste territoire estrade pendant près de
deux semaines la grc a passé ce
territoire au peigne fin sans trouver
aucun indice nos policiers savent est
qu'il suffirait de découvrir un seul
élément de preuve pour faire avancer
cette enquête
cet élément les policiers l'ont
finalement repéré vendredi ils ont
retrouvé le long du fleuve nelson une
chaloupe et sur le rivage des objets
appartenant aux fugitifs
la zone de recherches a été réduit et ce
matin le corps de deux hommes ont été
retrouvés à un kilomètre de là une
autopsie doit être pratiquée demain pour
confirmer leur identité mais ce soir peu
de doutes subsistent nous sommes
confiants que ces corps sont ceux des
deux suspects recherchés en lien aux
homicides survenus ou en colombie
britannique
parmi les victimes ce couple de
touristes china 10 une américaine de 24
ans et lucas sport le originaire de
l'australie dont le père s'est déplacé
en colombie britannique pour tenter de
trouver une explication à la mort de son
fils
bouille juste courges nous sommes tout
simplement démoli avait-il confié au
moment où la chasse à l'homme commençait
cela n'aurait jamais dû arriver à notre
famille avait ajouté la maire de china
la grc espère que ce dénouement
apportera un soulagement aux familles
des victimes
riot games qui est calme et cloud avait
aussi été accusé du meurtre au second
degré de léonard dès qu un homme de 64
ans qui enseignait la beauté n'est que
l'université de la colombie britannique
les policiers assurent aux familles que
la découverte de ces deux corps ne met
pas fin à l' enquête mais admettent
qu'il sera difficile de trouver toutes
les réponses à leurs questions à
certaines quant aux familles des
suspects elle n'a formulé aucun
commentaire sur la porte de la résidence
de la grand mère de brian nygaard
il y avait ce message où la famille
demande que l'on respecte son intimité
pour traverser cette épreuve ici valérie
gamache radio canada vancouver